madame monsieur bonsoir et si nous
parlions de tchernobyl voici plus d'un
mois que la catastrophe s'est produite
et l'on commence tout juste à imaginer
les conditions de l'accident et ses
conséquences à court et à moyen terme
car moscou fournit maintenant des
informations qu'ils se font de plus en
plus précise à savoir qu'il y a 21 morts
que 299 personnes sont encore
hospitalisées et que parmi elles 80 sont
d'ores et déjà condamnés à mort
et puis il ya cette révélation d'une
radiologiste d'un hôpital de moscou qui
annonce qu'un millier de personnes ont
été dangereusement ou très
dangereusement irradie enfin il y à ces
images qui nous venons de recevoir
regardez là elles sont impressionnantes
et voici commenté par patrick estève 34
jours après malgré la mort de 21 de
leurs compagnons les techniciens de
tchernobyl ont réinvesti la centrale
mongi héros des temps modernes
peu importe qu'ils connaissent la peur
le site devait être décontaminés pour
pouvoir y retravailler alors ils vont le
faire absolument invisible le danger
partout autour d'eux implacable déjà les
dizaines de pelle mécanique des caps une
couche superficielle de terre pour
l'enfermer dans des containers le visage
protégé par un masque
les hommes passent la terre contaminée
par la radioactivité nous sommes
maintenant à quelques dizaines de mètres
seulement du réacteur numéro 4 accidenté
personne ne peut s'aventurer jusqu'ici
des bulldozer télécommande et ouvre un
chemin sur le sol contaminé pour
permettre ensuite plus passage des
heures le tout à quelques centaines de
mètres de là d'autres techniciens
injectent d'azoté liquide dans le sol
afin de geler toute infiltration d'eau
radioactive vers le fleuve tout proche
weepu qui dans cette salle de commande
les équipes surveillent le réacteur
numéro un mise en sommeil après la
catastrophe lui aussi doit être
refroidie en permanence les soviétiques
espère le remettre à pleine puissance
avant la fin de l'année dans la même
salle
d'autres experts tentent de comprendre
comment l'accident et charles louis de
cession selon un rapport du commissariat
à l'énergie atomique français
la catastrophe aurait pu être lourd
grave encore sans le courage de ces
hommes deux d'entre eux vêtus de
combinaisons ont plongé dans une cuve
d'eau radioactive situé sous le réacteur
en fusion pour la vider évitant ainsi le
gigantesque explosion de vapeur sont
reproduits le coeur chauffer à 2000
degrés au contact de l'eau